I'm a little bit nervous about getting
the rating today just because I'm like
what if it says we're not compatible we
have to get divorce I can be arranged my
name is Chris I'm trynna my name is
Jenna and I'm a writer for BuzzFeed we
met in high school we actually met Amy
nine
yeah we're in science class together and
we found we had some good chemistry
that's ruined Jenna being like the smart
kid in the class was always coming first
off towards the topping which is ahead
of me which is annoying we used to
compete to try and get top of the class
and IO is one we've seen one class which
one was economics or Business Studies
just be me what I love most about Chris
is he's so open-minded I feel like I can
tell him anything and he doesn't judge
me at all
Chris's most quality is he kind of tends
to bottle up his emotions rather than
talking about them Jenna's worst quality
is that she's very messy yeah
that's all it is that she's sometimes
not as messy
how about Jenna's very ambitious in life
and inspires others I'm interested
really can see what comes from what do
you think gonna come from it have no
expectations at all okay hi I'm Lexi
Lafleur and I'm a Sydney based
astrologer today I've got two charts in
front of me Chris and Jenna's so we're
gonna start with Sun science Jenna's
sign is a Taurus Taurus is an earth sign
Jenna you would be very practical very
grounded very logical very calm but
extremely stubborn and extremely set in
your ways horses are always working
their life is very much based around
work Tauruses do not like to be wrong
this is like one of the most well known
traits of a Taurus this is because you
usually are right you usually are really
well researched but
you know you're human and you are wrong
and I just don't feel like Jenna you're
gonna be admitting that to Chris too
often Chris you are you're sunshine
you're an Aries and Aries is a fire sign
you Chris are really kind of quite
sporadic quite impulsive quite
changeable and flexible and together
sometimes you might butt heads but it's
a really beautiful combination because
you gender would be very consistent and
grounding for Chris and Chris would be
really exciting and passionate and
engaging for you Jenna
yes pretty rough in jail I'm definitely
stubborn I'm always right
I was working I'm always working yeah I
was really surprised by that I didn't
know that was a tourist thing but that
explains a lot about me with Jenna we'll
start with you and your moon sign your
moon sign is a Leo Leo is super playful
super proud super loyal super passionate
definitely Leo's hate to lose love to
win and really can get under your skin
you Chris have an Aquarius moon which is
so cool and it's also kind of got a bad
rap as being the most unemotional sign
Chris like sometimes I feel like in a
partnership you would be quite hard to
read emotionally because although you're
Aries Sun is expressive and fun and
known to be emotional there would be a
lot of things that you hold in your
Aquarius moon kind of like a little
vault
and your partner would definitely sense
and be frustrated that you do seem
really cold or detached or just
unwilling to go into that emotional
vault oh my god
that explains so much because I have no
emotions at all Jenna your mercury sign
isn't Taurus which is consistent with
your Sun Sign but it's also really
intense like it's a Taurus double whammy
so for Chris I kind of feel sorry for
you like just thinking like how are you
gonna argue against general with like
her Mercury sign and Taurus is just
there's kind of no winning Jenna like
you're really really sure of yourself
you're really assertive when you're
communicating Jenna if you feel like
upset or wrong you're going to be quite
a drama queen about it because
you moon and your tourists sunshine and
your tourists mercury is really not
gonna want to admit that so Chris your
mercury sign isn't Pisces Pisces are all
about feeling they have their own kind
of internal reality Jenna you probably
are the one often asking Chris how he
feels and wanting to resolve and work
through and talk through things and
Chris you don't really bring up conflict
and communicate it and want to go into
it sometimes that's like frustrating -
in a partnership that was spot on yeah
so you just will polarize to you then to
fight I never win Jenna your Venus is in
Gemini and this changes everything this
is super compatible with Chris you're
extremely flexible in the ways that you
can give and show love and you want
variety in the ways that you receive
love Chris
Venus is in Taurus so you've also got a
little bit of that Torian energy and
this is really good news for the two of
you the ways that you give love to Jenna
and show care to Jenna is super grounded
undeniable realistic practical maybe at
times like a little boring but Jenna
really loves it in terms of Chris's love
sign I think that definitely sounds
right to me like rather than expressing
his emotions which is what my immediate
response is his immediate response well
what can I do so Jenna and Chris I think
ultimately your charts are super
compatible you definitely have your
challenges but they're super minor and
they're definitely workable looking at
your whole chart
everything is so beautifully balanced
and mixed it's quite interesting and
crazy I don't think I've seen a more
compatible chart so I think the cool
challenge for you guys would be like if
Chris you could just be a little bit
more verbal with your emotions and your
expressions - Jenna should probably
really appreciate that and Jenna I think
if you could sometimes give Chris the
space to be not so well formulated not
so assertive and not so put together and
not so knowing how he feels I'm talking
divorce and I think that is a good start
I feel relieved that we're compatible
according to astrology
Chris the least accurate was actually me
a sunshine like that it wasn't a hundred
percent accurate but then let everything
else is like okay when you bring all
body in its explained so much about our
relationship and the way we interact and
I think the advice she gave it like is
mr. Prater express my feelings more are
you glad that we're compatible I knew we
were that now the stars say we are as
well
[Music]